♪ ♪
SPEAK WITH A FAMILY OF A MARINE
KILLED DURING THE U.S. IS
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN IS
FLAPPING OUT ALEC BOLTON WITH A
LAWSUIT.
THE FEDERAL LAWSUIT WAS FILED BY
THE FAMILY AFTER MARINE LANCE
CORPORAL, 1 OF 13 MARINES KILLED
BY THE SUICIDE BOMBER OUTSIDE OF
THE KABUL AIRPORT IN AFGHANISTAN
LAST YEAR.
IT IS THE SECOND TIME THEY HAVE
ACCUSED THE ACTOR FOR BEING
NEGLIGENT AND RECKLESS AND
POSTING ABOUT THE SISTER BEING
AT THE JANUARY 6TH PROTEST.
ALEC BALDWIN IS ALSO UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR HIS ROLE IN
THE SHOOTING DEATH OF SAM AND A
PHOTOGRAPHER ON HIS "RUST" MOVIE
SET.
BUT DESPITE ALL THIS BROADWAY TO
ROLL OUT THE CARPET FOR HIS
COMBAT.
ALEC BOLTON WILL START SET TO
OPEN IN THE SPRING.
AND FIRST, KAYLEIGH ON THIS
DEFINITION GOING AFTER THIS
FALLEN HERO.
>> Kayleigh: I'M SO HAPPY THEY
ARE TRYING TO HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY SHOULD HAVE
ENOUGH TO WORRY ABOUT INSTEAD OF
ATTACKING A FAMILY OF A FALLEN
HERO.
THE FALLEN HERO, HIS DAUGHTER 14
DAYS AFTER PAST, HER NAME IS
LEVI RILEY, SEPTEMBER 13TH, 2021
AND NEVER MET HER HEROIC FATHER.
THIS IS HOW WE SHOULD BE
SPEAKING OF THIS FAMILY OF THIS
FALLEN HERO, ACKNOWLEDGING THE
LOSS AND HIS DAUGHTER WILL NEVER
MEET THIS YOUNG MAN.
NOT ATTACKING HIS AUNT.
PUTTING YOUR FOLLOWERS ON
HER, WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
ALEC BALDWIN DID APPEAR IN AND
THIS BEAUTIFUL LITTLE BABY
SAYING WHEN I SENT YOU MONEY, I
DIDN'T KNOW THIS ABOUT YOU AND
ATTACKING HER.
WHO DOES THAT?
THIS IS SO SICK, EVEN FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S DONE A LOT OF
WRONG IN HIS
LIFE, ALEC BALDWIN, AND I HOPE
THEY PREVAIL.
>> THEY ARE FIGHTING BACK AND WE
WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THEY WERE SO MUCH CONTROVERSY
SURROUNDING A LEG PULLED WENT
AFTER THE CEMENT PHOTOGRAPHER'S
DEATH.
AND THE INTERVIEWS HE GAVE ABOUT
IT.
A LAWYER WILL TELL YOU DON'T
SPEAK WHEN AN INVESTIGATION IS
PENDING AND HE WANTS TO MAKE A
COMEBACK ON BROADWAY.
CASSIE, I WILL TAKE THIS OVER TO
YOU BECAUSE BROADWAY SNAKE
WELCOME HIM BACK OPEN ARMS, BUT
WILL THE PATRONS?
>> THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION AND
I'M SO GLAD KAYLEIGH YOU BROUGHT
UP THE NAME OF HIS DAUGHTER.
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THAT AND WE SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT IT.
HERE AGAIN, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
ALEC BALDWIN AND HE ALWAYS MAKES
IT ABOUT HIMSELF.
AND THE QUESTION ABOUT
BROADWAY, GO TO A SHOW.
IF I GET TO COME TO NEW YORK, IT
IS EXPENSIVE.
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY A
REALLY SPECIAL TRIP TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY WILL
WELCOME ALEC BALDWIN APPEAR AT
THE THEATER COMMUNITY, THE
HOLLYWOOD ELITES, BUT I DON'T
THINK HE'S DONE ENOUGH IN HIS
OWN LIFE TO SHOW US THIS IS A MN
WORTHY OF FORGIVENESS OF THE
REDEMPTION.
>> Brett: IT IS TOO EARLY FOR
THAT.
>> WHAT IS SO INTERESTING HE
LOST FIVE JOBS AS A RESULT OF
THE CONTROVERSY AFTER THE
SHOOTING.
MORGAN, I SAY TO MYSELF, ARE YOU
REALLY PLAYING THE VICTIM HERE?
IS THIS THE SAME GUY WHOSE WIFE
BAKED SPANISH?
[LAUGHTER]
OKAY, SO HILARIOUS.
I HAVE WORDS BUT I WILL GET
KICKED OFF OF SET FOR THIS MAN.
WHAT HE DID TO THE FAMILY.
LISTEN, FOR THE ECONOMICS OF A
BROADWAY SHOW, I HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS INVESTED IN HIM AND
ACTUALLY HARD TO GET YOUR MONEY
BACK TO RECOUP IT SO I GET THE
IDEA OF TRYING TO PUT A
BIG, BOLD NAME TO GET PEOPLE
INTO.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T WORK.
I HOPE HE AND HIS BIG SPANISH
WIFE GO AWAY.
>> Brett: IT IS TOO EARLY TO
COME BACK.
I DO THINK ALEC BALDWIN HAS NOT
ADDRESSED THE SEVERITY OF THE
SHOOTING AND PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
IF YOU KILL SOMEBODY, YOU
KNOW, YOU SHOULD BE REMORSEFUL.
WE HEARD IS HE WASN'T THE ONE
WHO PULLED THE TRIGGER.
THE GUN JUST WENT OFF WHICH IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR THAT TO
EVEN HAPPEN.
WE CAN'T WHISTLE PAST THIS ISSUE
WITH WHAT HE HAS DONE THERE.
THE OTHER THING, WHY IS HE NOT
DOING GUN SAFETY?
WHY IS HE NOT OUT THERE TRYING
TO HELP PEOPLE AFTER THIS
SERIES?
>> THAT WOULD BE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, BREAD.
>> INSTEAD OF SITTING DOWN AND
DOING THESE INTERVIEWS AND
SAYING, "I DIDN'T PULL THE
TRIGGER," YOU SHOULD SAY I'M
SORRY AND YOU SHOULD BE
REPEATING IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND SAYING NOTHING ELSE.
THAT IS WHAT A REASONABLE -- I'M
SURE HIS LAWYERS AREN'T TELLING
HIM THAT.
SPEAK IT THOUGH MAKES ME SICK
SMOKE AND MIRRORS TO GET THEM
BACK TO WORK BUT IF THE SAME
TIME, WE CAN'T FORGET THERE WAS
A LIFE LOST DURING THE
SITUATION.
AND SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT AND BE
REMORSEFUL.
>> HOW UNFORTUNATE THAT ONE'S
FAMILY HAS TO HEAR HIM OVER AND
OVER HIM LIVING ON HIS LIFE AND
HIS DAUGHTER DOMINIC THEIR
DAUGHTER CAN'T.
>> HE HAS A SELF MANDATE.
HE FEELS LIKE HE SHOULD WIN SO
MANY PEOPLE WOULD SAY, WHY DON'T
YOU STICK TO WHAT YOU ARE GOOD
AT.
>> Kayleigh: EXACTLY.
THIS FAMILY SAID HE DONATED
$5,000 TO RILEY'S FAMILY.
AND THINK TO
YOURSELF, DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN,
IN A HUMAN WITH AN OUNCE OF
DECENCY, WHAT WOULD COMPEL YOU
TO MESSAGE, PRIVATE MESSAGE AND
ESSENTIALLY PUT OUT YOUR
FOLLOWERS AND TWEAK YOUR
FOLLOWERS ABOUT THIS FAMILY AND
WHAT WOULD COMPEL YOU TO DO THAT
TO A FAMILY OF A FALLEN SOLDIER
IN AFGHANISTAN.
THAT SPEAKS TO A LEVEL OF
ARROGANCE AND TOTAL SELFISHNESS
THAT I DON'T THINK A RATIONAL
HUMAN BEING WOULD THINK ABOUT.
>> I'M SURPRISED HE CAN'T TOUCH
INSIDE HIS PATERNAL INSTINCT
THERE.
YOU ARE A FATHER OF SO MANY
CHILDREN.